revista de prensa en directo América de
Francia 24 Marta Moya ya está conmigo en
el estudio Marta bienvenida buena mañana
de martes empezamos hoy destacando lo
que sigue siendo la noticia más
destacada de toda la prensa
internacional lamentablemente es otra No
es otra que la escalada de Rusia en
Ucrania hoy destaca la mayoría de las
portadas en la prensa impresa alrededor
del mundo y empezamos con liberación de
Francia Buenos días Raúl Así es
unanimidad en casi todas las portadas de
la prensa internacional especialmente la
occidental por supuesto el Liberación
titula misiles rusos en Ucrania la
estrategia del terror se ve a esta mujer
con la cabeza vendada llena de sangre en
kiev y dice que dos días después del
ataque al puente de crimea kiev y otras
ciudades ucranianas amanecieron bajo las
bombas en el día de ayer y que esta es
este es un paso más en la huida asesina
de Putin vamos con el país de España
Marta el país película La venganza de
Putin se ceba con las ciudades en
Ucrania vemos Esta foto de glef garage
en la que se ve a este chico huyendo en
el centro de kiev después de la caída de
uno de estos misiles y sostiene este
titular del país que la represalias de
Putin se centraron en los ataques a la
población civil
titula celenski pide más ayuda para
combatir los ataques terroristas rusos
destaca también esta portada de la
prensa británica las palabras del
presidente francés Emmanuel macron
destacando que Ucrania está enfrentando
un profundo cambio en la naturaleza de
la guerra vamos ahora en Estados Unidos
destaca varias fotos de los ataques con
misiles en ciudades como harkies
zaporiya kiev o nipro y titula Rusia
desata un bombardeo mortal contra
civiles destaca además que estos ataques
son un signo de presión a Putin e por
las facciones más ultranacionalistas que
ya le venían pidiendo al presidente ruso
que atacara con más vehemencia a Ucrania
en nuestra región de América del Sur El
Clarín de Argentina Pues esta esta
portada titula kiev otra vez bajo el
fuego misiles misiles y muerte Perdón es
el primer ataque aquí desde el mes de
junio y es la mayor ofensiva rusa en
ciudades ucranianas en semanas con 84
misiles de crucero y 24 drones destaca
esta portada del clarín la prensa
gráfica Marta también no y casi
monográfica sobre los ataques rusos ayer
en la ciudad de ucranianas como ya lo
estábamos reportando viendo los
principales portadas no especialmente en
kiev la capital del país que viñetas y
caricaturas vamos a ver esta mañana Pues
sí Raúl hemos destacado cuatro empezamos
por el Washington post Es una caricatura
de and Tennis que titula objetivos
militares rusos En referencia a las
palabras de ayer del presidente ruso
Vladimir Putin en las que decía que los
misiles se habían lanzado contra
objetivos estratégicos en la imagen sin
embargo vemos un columpio infantil
rodeado por este por estos Círculos que
simbolizan el objetivo militar en lo que
parece ser pues que no es efectivamente
un objetivo militar como es pues un
parque infantil ahora Marta cambiando de
tema aunque no nos vamos a alejar de
digamos
seguir comentando tres portadas del
cartoon movement empezamos por una
caricatura de la austriaca Marian
kamensky que titula operación asesina
especial de Putin en la que vemos a un
soldado ucraniano intentando disparar a
objetivos rusos y a Putin que ha acabado
una zanja y por detrás dispara a
objetivos civiles representados en este
carrito de bebé continuamos con otra
caricatura de El caricaturista de Países
Bajos Martin walternick que titula
cambio de estrategia Dice que ahora que
está perdiendo todo en Ucrania se se
convierte en un objetivo legítimo
militar para Vladimir Putin vemos al
presidente con unos rotuladores que se
va mientras o sea después de haber
pintado en esta pizarra la estrategia
militar de atacar a civiles Y por último
destacamos una caricatura de lucraniano
andrey petrenco que dice Putin es el
primer terrorista y vemos al presidente
otra vez lanzando decenas de misiles
mortíferos de su boca Qué triste no lo
que estamos viendo en este momento en
Ucrania Ahora sí vamos a cambiar de tema
pero no vamos a dejar de la guerra
porque vamos a sacar un artículo del
medio estadounidense político que dice
que el jefe de la ciberseguridad
Alemania será despedido por sus vínculos
con Moscú así a Raúl hablamos de arnet
John born y titula este
artículo del político de Estados Unidos
que podría ser despedido de manera
inminente le podrían quedar pocas horas
en el cargo después de que una
investigación de la emisora pública zdf
publicara los vínculos de la empresa de
la oficina Federal para la seguridad de
la información con empresas rusas dice
que esta investigación el líder de esta
agencia tiene vínculos estrechos al
Estado de Vladimir Putin que en 2012
este jefe de La ciberseguridad alemana
fundó un Grupo Industrial llamado
consejo de seguridad
industrial cibernética que según los
medios alemanos alemanes Perdón está
comprometido con los intereses rusos ha
sido víctima del espionaje y tiene
influencia en empresas rusas y además de
las de la inteligencia rusa de Moscú la
figura de este de esa persona del jefe
de la ciberseguridad ya fue
controvertida Raúl en desde el inicio en
2016 y ahora según informa pues la
revista alemana there's beagle como
decíamos podía tener las horas contadas
Marta Gracias como siempre por toda la
información mañana con más lista de
prensa mañana